are you ready sir didn't get dressed up
for nothing
[Music]
it will kill
a pair of viking war axes
during the viking age the viking war
acts evolved from a common farming tool
to a fearsome weapon of war its wooden
shaft and single-headed blade made it
well balanced and light enough to
repeatedly deliver hefty swings with
fierce cleaving power the curved blade
head could be used to hook any part of
the opponent's body to forcibly draw
them in closer for a deadly attack the
razor sharp edge could penetrate armor
and bone with frightening ease today
viking war axes can be seen wielded by
characters and television shows such as
vikings
as you know i'm still nursing an injury
to be my arm today i'm bringing a
special guest from architect please
welcome staff sergeant chris manz today
he will be my arm or arms to test your
weapons finish you up first you ready
let's do it
[Music]
yeah all right chris let's talk about
your viking war axes on the initial cut
the long beard that you have right there
hooked all the ribs and of course the
beauty of having a secondary weapon is
that when he pulled it out he had enough
attacks to disembowel everything overall
sir your viking war axe
will kill
thank you
jeremiah shall we do this yes we shall
all right jeremiah your viking war axes
are razor sharp it not only blew through
the ribs but dug in breaking through the
lungs and into the heart it is fast and
light
and it will kill
thank you
all right bladesmiths next up is the
strength test dave
to test the strength and overall
construction of your war axes i'll be
throwing them three times with each axe
into our mock-up of a drawbridge now
hopefully they'll stay tight and right
not loosen up
chris you ready yeah let's do it
[Music]
all right chris first off they're
balanced nicely and they match which is
really what i was looking for that stout
edge though kind of keeps them from
penetrating overly deep
you can see right about here
is just a small roll and two spots but
they're solid they're still together
nicely done thank you
jeremiah you ready didn't get dressed up
for nothing
[Laughter]
so first off jeremiah they feel like
they weigh the same they definitely
throw the same and having that curve on
the blade allows it to dig a lot deeper
than having a flat edge but the bottom
line is neither of your blades took any
damage well done
thank you
next up the sharpness test and for that
i'll give you the bend
to test the sharpness of your blades see
how they held up i'm going to take your
axes and deliver three shots to these
three fish
chris you're up first you ready yeah
let's do it
well chris the gods of war will be happy
there's blood on your axe it's a good
day
the shape of that blade now it's a
little concerned just because it's flat
but it really just cut right through
those fish very very sharp blades well
done thank you sir
jeremiah you're up you ready time for
sushi
[Music]
well jeremiah same effect your axes are
bloodied they're now honorable viking
war axes they are beautiful i like what
you did with the copper night
not
a huge fan and how thin the handles are
to swing it took a little bit more
finger gripping
two very well-made axes
obviously sharp well done thank you
[Music]
chris jeremiah the judges have examined
your work and they've tested your
weapons they've made their final
decision the forged and fire champion is
jeremiah
congratulations
chris
your axis did not make the cut please
surrender your war axis
you're always disappointed if you don't
win but the experience that you get from
this competition
i've loved every minute of it i'm gonna
go back home and keep making knives and
i'll probably make a viking axe on the
side
jeremiah congratulations you are a new
force and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10
grand how do you feel that's amazing you
did excellent work please present your
access to the judges
i did it i won fortune fire to be
validated as a smith this way is really
cool this is a win for my family
certainly a win for the history book
stay in school
study your history it'll come in handy
frank tony congratulations you've made
it to the final round of this
competition which means that you're both
one step closer to the title and 10
grand
now we're sending you back to your home
for just to recreate an iconic weapon
from history
the sick a
sword the sikka is a short but dangerous
sword widely used by gladiators in
ancient rome since it was customary to
fight with armor the blade featured a
sharp curve specifically designed to get
around an opponent's shield a gruesome
killer warriors would use its lethal
inner edge to sever limbs or the blade's
deadly point to hook into the jaw and
pierce through the head today the sick
is often depicted in popular culture
during graphic gladiator battles most
notably in the television series
spartacus blood and sand
blade smiths this is the kill test i'll
take your zika sword and deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy
frank you're up first you ready hell
yeah let's do this
nice
well frank your blade is sharp
in combat the sikka is sometimes using
its curve to pull away the sword and
come in in this case he pulled away the
head overall your weapon
will kill thank you
tony you ready mm-hmm let's have some
fun
all right tony this is a scary sicka
sword on the initial hack into the chest
cavity it penetrated so deep it totally
demolished this ballistics dummy overall
sir your weapon
will kill
tony's blade just performs great on this
thing i mean even though they both will
kill it's just looked a little bit more
violent so it has me a little a little
nervous
gentlemen this is the strength test in
order to test the strength and
durability of your blades i'm going to
attack these shields
remember this test is all about what the
shields do to your weapons and not what
your weapons do to the shields frank
you're up first are you ready yep let's
do this
[Music]
well frank
your edge held up perfectly all right
it's still straight
it's still sharp
everything is still tight and solid
well done thank you
tony you're up next you ready yes
well tony
your edge held up perfectly as well
razor sharp i see
no problem with the edge from the shield
you know
a nice solid blade well done thank you
good job
all right gentlemen
now it's the sharpness test i'll be
cutting through this sugar cane one cut
with the front edge of your blade one
cut with the back edge all right frank
you're up first you ready oh yes
[Music]
all right frank right off your blade's
got a really nice balance to it
you can see on that first cut it kind of
pulled in my hand but it's still a good
feel on the back cut blew right through
any gladiator using this be quick be
deadly hold on thank you all right tony
you're up you ready for this yep
[Music]
so tony
is it sharp yes it's very sharp and it
cut very nicely
still right still tight
hold on thanks
blade smith's over the course of three
rounds both of you has displayed
excellent bladesmithing talents however
in this arena of competition there can
only be one champion
tony
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion
frank unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut
frank first stop i want to say that
there are no losers in this round but we
can only pick one winner both weapons
were very sharp both weapons are very
strong but the sikko was a gladiator's
weapon and your weapon was outperformed
in the kill test as for that reason
we're sending you home i
totally understand frank please
surrender your blade
i'm fine with this result they both
killed but
he's uh really killed
tony's already invited me to come up
there and forge he's gonna show me some
stuff
i'll know tony probably the rest of my
life
tony congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job how do you feel right now
i feel pretty good
all right well tony please present your
weapon to the judges
just
okay i'm still here it's not a dream
i won it's awesome
how do you put it in words
game i saw in a concord
the key long g
the key long g is a chinese pole arm
made famous during the han dynasty in
the second century
over six feet long the key long g
featured a fierce point for stabbing and
slashing the crescent of the weapon was
equally dangerous and could be employed
to dismount oncoming cavalry or tear
away enemy shields a skilled user could
also use the crescent portion to ward
off enemy attacks
however the key long g was at its
deadliest when employed in mass creating
a terrifying spear wall that kept foes
at a distance
the key long g is the famed weapon of
lubu legendary warrior featured in the
television series three kingdoms
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will inflict lethal
cuts and thrust on both these ballistics
dummies
jason you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
uh
that was the coolest thing i've ever
seen
all right jason this weapon is fast it's
maneuverable your tip here is sharp
enough to penetrate and lacerate on the
way out
the only one issue here is that it did
pick up a bend but overall your weapon
sir will kill
thanks
all right spicy mike you ready let's do
it let's do this
that's awesome
did i do that
spicy mike you're a kilongji it's wide
enough to break bone as i was thrusting
into the chest cavity it's a light fast
weapon and most importantly it will kill
thank you
all right gentlemen now it's my turn to
strength test to test the strength and
overall construction of your keylon g's
i will be using the crescent part of the
blade to try to break off these spears
then it's onto the drum stab using the
front edge of that blade now remember
this test is not about what your blades
do to the target but what these targets
can do to your blades
all right jason you're up are you ready
yes sir okay
all right jason well this has got some
serious heft to it
that bend didn't change any what i do
like to see is the fact that your edges
are just fine it's a strong weapon
definitely did what it's supposed to do
it's a good job thank you
all right michael you ready yeah
awesome
all right well your weapon is still in
one piece
it's still sharp didn't lose any of that
blade at all it's well done good one
thank you
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
the banner raise using the crescent's
edge i will cut the rope thereby raising
the banner then i will test your flan
bearish by slicing on the banner
jason you're first you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
it was neat
all right jason
your crescent blade is very sharp it cut
cleanly through the rope one and done
the edges of your flamberries are sharp
the tip easily pierced it and sliced all
the way down
overall sir your weapon will cut
all right michael your turn you ready
let's do it let's do this
[Music]
all right mike on your crescent blade
the edge is sharp your flambe is over
here the point is sharp the edges are
sharp it was very easy to slide down
overall sir your weapon will cut
jason michael you guys brought us
exactly what we asked for some high
performance finale weapons they're both
fantastic
but unfortunately there can only be one
force and fire champion
mike
you are the new forged and fire champion
jason
unfortunately your weapon did not make
the cut
you guys both brought us great weapons
but jason during the kill test your
weapon developed a bend and that's a
structural issue that's why we're going
to send you home yes sir jason please
surrender your blade i didn't come in
here to finish second i mean honestly
i'm disappointed but i gained a lot
through this process
spicy mike congratulations you are a new
force and fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check for 10 000
good job man
this is like the proudest moment in my
entire life well congratulations man you
did some fantastic work please present
your blade to our judges
i i won
i'm this crazy guy with a weird nickname
for the middle of nowhere but
i did it
oh what do i do where do i go go get
money okay
i gotta get some stuff paid off but
after that
i gotta think about it
the nine-ring broadsword
the nine-ring broadsword is a variant on
the chinese dow from the king dynasty
that was used through the 1930s
featuring a blade wider than a
traditional dowel and a curve towards
the tip the weapon was ideal for
chopping and could sever a head with a
single swing
the rings on the back of the blade serve
dual purposes for ornamentation used
during ceremonies or martial arts
displays and for superstitious reasons
as it was believed the jingling sound
would ward off evil spirits this deadly
and sacred sword can be seen on the
television show into the badlands
bladesmiths
you have our gratitude
gentlemen your swords look magnificent
but are they deadly
to find that out we will take your soul
to deliver some killing blows on this
pig carcass
it's all about the kill in this
particular test britain you are first
are you ready sir yes sir
let's do this
two
[Music]
look at that
all right burton first stop
what i love about this blade was the
balance the way i was able to move with
the blade everywhere
now let's talk about the breakage
okay
so the break happened right there where
the ring was attached
you can see it's really not a bad poor
scratcher you have there it could be
finer but rings when you're digging into
that could cause stress risers and it
broke right there where the ring was
well gentlemen the fight's not over
because mike your blade still has to
survive nine strikes on its kill test
target good luck gentlemen doug
if i make it through nine strikes on
this pig i'm forging fire champion my
palms are sweating i'm so scared that
this thing's gonna break on the first
swing
[Applause]
[Music]
so good job bro
burton unfortunately your blade broke
and can no longer continue with testing
and for that reason i have to dismiss
you from the forge
good job brother for sure it sucks i'm
still proud of myself with what i've
done you know it was way out of my
wheelhouse uh what's next for me is not
swords especially any nine ring swords
that's for damn sure
mike congratulations the strength and
integrity of your blade has made you a
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother
i have unfortunate fire holy crap man
come on forward and shake our hands
thank you thank you
good job bro thank you because some of
the things that went wrong in my home
forge i was really sure that that blade
was gonna break on me
it's a happy dance
[Music]
one of the most intimidating and
versatile japanese pole weapons the soto
gourami was part of the key arsenal for
samurai police during the 17th century
featuring lethal spikes and hooks police
were able to capture violent offenders
from the distance by using the weapon to
latch onto the suspects stopping them in
their tracks although primarily used in
defense the sharp spikes along with the
spiked bud cap made it a menacing and
brutal weapon when in combat today the
soto gourami's devastating use can be
seen in the hbo television series
westworld all right bladesmiths welcome
to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your sonicarami will do i will take your
weapons and stab and try to snag this
ballistic dummy rita you are first you
ready for this hi
all right let's do this
all right rita let's talk about your
saudigarami the times you have here
penetrates the hook you have here will
rip this person apart
and more importantly your weapon
will kill
all right justin your turn you ready
have fun yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
all right justin the times you have here
it's more of a stabbing time rather than
a grabbing this is a grabbing weapon but
that hook does grab onto that overall
sir your weapon
will kill
all right bladesmiths it's time for the
strength test the dreaded ice block chop
remember this is not about what these
weapons do to the ice blocks but with
those ice blocks due to your weapons and
rita you're up first you get points for
theme i mean
you ready
it doesn't matter right oh it doesn't
matter
hmm
[Music]
all right rita got a little bit more of
a bend in this one tine here
but everything else is pretty much the
way it was going in
definitely held up did his job good job
thank you
all right justin your turn you ready yes
i am
so
all right so you survived the strength
test this is a very strong uh well-built
head for this but it's built more like a
spear than it is for catching i mean i'm
not sure how effective it would be at
snagging the opponent but uh it's a
devastator it certainly did the job good
job
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
sharpness test the sandman pierce and
capture
to test the sharpness i will take your
weapon pierce and try to control this
sandman relay you're first you ready for
this
[Music]
all right rita the points you have on
your tines here definitely penetrate
when you thrust into that but it doesn't
slice on the way out or capture as well
as it should
your hook over here did its job overall
it will cut in control
all right justin your turn so you ready
yes i am
that's not good
he pulled it out of the socket
well just we have a problem yes sir this
wasn't pinned was it no the impact from
all these tests loosened it up and of
course it came off
justin you brought in a beautifully
crafted weapon however you've suffered a
catastrophic failure in our final test
and unfortunately you cannot be our
fortune fire champion congratulations
rita thank you awesome
coming on forrest and fire i put my all
into it and i feel like i made a good
weapon but uh just came up short on a
little bit of the fit and finish and
other than that i'm happy with it
[Music]
rita congratulations you
are the force and fire champion and that
is the title that comes with a check for
10 000 congratulations
how do you feel right now
come on forward and shake our hands
good job
it's been a very positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do something
amazing like this
i hope this will help me become an
inspiration
to kids because i can say look if you
see something and you want to try it
give it a try hey we blows your scout
leader is the new fortune fire champion
i'm bringing it home
can i have a group hug please
thank you you guys oh my god
you